and one last quick announcement about
the salsa it's become this thing now
dj selva is he here
dj selva in the house way at the back
corner so he has hooked it up that we're
gonna go to havana
kl tonight and i'm going to be djing for
a set
so if you like salsa or if you just want
to have a good time or here's some music
come on out it starts at nine o'clock
there's a lesson it goes on i'm gonna be
there hope to meet you guys and one last
thing for you guys we as the speakers
come here the best part is meeting you
right like i come here and talk as much
as i want but i love talking to you guys
and i've had some great conversations
don't be afraid to come up and find me
afterwards to talk to me don't be afraid
to find any of these speakers because
that's the that's the most rewarding
part for us you have a question you guys
have paid good money to be here you have
a question what i answered come and talk
to us we love but you're not imposing on
us
and
believe you